[Musique]
au coeur de la nouvelle écosse dans la
petite ville d'antigonish l'université
saint francis xavier a formé des
générations de leaders canadiens
en cet après midi de mai 2015 une
nouvelle cohorte de diplômés s'apprête à
joindre les rangs des lustres
politiciens comme brian mulroney nos
efforts sur scène un invité spécial à
qui l'université sur le point de
remettre une de ses plus hautes
distinctions le mystérieux milliardaire
d'origine syrienne
ouafik saïd reçoit un doctorat
honorifique pour ses oeuvres
philanthropiques sans compte souffre le
mot ne sont pas ces troubles
il ne semble avoir aucun lien avec
l'université ou même avec le canada
aucun lien sauf un son amitié avec
l'ancien premier ministre mulroney
[Musique]
qui donc coiffic saïd et pourquoi être
si proche de l'ancien premier ministre
canadien les périodes respectueuse la
nouvelle fuite de documents
confidentiels des paradis fiscaux
obtenus par le journal allemand
süddeutsche zeitung nous ont permis de
découvrir des indices étonnant sur les
liens qui unissent ces deux hommes au
passé controversé
originaire de syrie ouafik rida saïd
abid cap sur londres dans les années 60
il a rapidement gravi des échelons de la
société britannique amassant une fortune
de plus d'un milliard de dollars ou à
fixer n'hésite pas à donner pour des
causes qui lui sont chères dont la
prestigieuse école d'études commerciales
l'université oxford qui porte son nom
il gravite autour des grands et
puissants de ce monde que deux personnes
mandela au prince charles en passant par
margaret thatcher
j'ai entendu son nom parce qu'il
apparaissait dans les pages social de
journaux respectable et j'ai voulu
savoir comment cet homme a fait son
argent
et qu'avez vous découvert
qu'il était un marchand d'armes depuis
nombre enjoy einstein dirige une ong
copte chinois tx et a écrit sur le
commerce mondial des armes
ça y est l'histoire de wafiq saïd est
intéressante
il a fait la connaissance de nombreux
membres de la famille royale saoudienne
et compris du prince bandar le prince
bandar est le fils du prince sultan qui
était à compter des années 60 le
ministre saoudien de la défense pendant
presqu'un demi siècle le prince bandar
et son père était au coeur des contrats
d'armes avec l'arabie saoudite
ce sont ces contacts loi fixe aïda mise
à profit dans un des plus gros contrats
de vente d'armes de l'histoire du
royaume-uni important contrat de vente
d'armes ne se produit pas sans
corruption de tunis en beauté mais vous
avez besoin de quelqu'un pour éloigner
les pots de vin du gouvernement ou de
l'entreprise et des bénéficiaires et
c'est le rôle de l'intermédiaire
ça c'est ce rôle que joue et wafiq sayid
dans la sphère al yamamah
conclu en 1985 le contrat surnommé à
yamamah allait atteindre plus de 70
milliards de dollars pour la vente et
l'entretien d'avions de chasse du
fabricant british aerospace à l'arabie
saoudite mais des soupçons de corruption
peut être dès le début concernant ce
contrat en 2003 le journaliste en quête
d velits a reçu l'appel d'un lanceur d'
alerte qui disait avoir été payée à même
une caisse noire de plus des charreaux
space
son rôle était de satisfaire les requins
et plus excentriques et prince saoudien
dit c'est mon travail de leur fournir
des voyages des filles et des sorties en
boîte de nuit
il a dit qu'il devait leur donner des
cadeaux des choses comme des coffrets
d'ustensiles en or puis des
dénonciateurs nous ont approchés en
disant vous n'avez aucune idée de ce qui
se passe n'est pas seulement propos de
prostituées et de couverts alors il
s'agit d'une affaire de gros sous
[Musique]
les journalistes du guardian ont ensuite
mis la main sur des documents
confidentiels qui avait été déposé par
erreur aux archives nationales
britanniques
et aussi sur cette note de l'ambassadeur
britannique en arabie saoudite
indiquant que le prince sultan
s'attendait à recevoir des pots de vin
dans tous les contrats
considérant les soupçons qui entourait
le contrat al yamamah c'était une
information explosive
nous avons donc pousser nos recherches
d'autres documents secrets obtenus par
guardian révèle entre autres que le coup
les avions de chasse britannique avait
été gonflé pour le paiement de
commissions secrètes des avions de
guerre vendus étaient surévalués de 30 à
40 pour ça ces montants supplémentaires
étaient facturées aux saoudiens wazemmes
puis distribuée sous forme de poudre un
contrôle au prince sultan
le ministre de la défense et à son fils
dindar une partie de l'argent allait
dans les poches des britanniques
le prince bandar lui même à le partager
publiquement sa vision de la corruption
lors d'une entrevue à la télévision
américaine en 2001 ce que j'essaie de
vous dire c'est que nous n'avons pas
inventé la corruption ça se passe depuis
adam g la nature humaine mais nous ne
sommes pas aussi mauvais qu'on pensait
à la suite des allégations de corruption
publié par djoko retiennent le service
britannique de la répression des fraudes
majeures le serious fraud office lance
en 2004 une enquête sur le contrat al
yamamah à la même époque un des
entremetteurs du contrat
le milliardaire ouafik saïd décide de
recruter un ex premier ministre canadien
pour l'aider à gérer sa fortune
personnelle
le 21 mai 2004 à paris brian mulroney
assiste à une réunion du conseil
d'administration de save holding la
société de gestion de la fortune de
wafiq saïd selon les procès verbaux
nous avons obtenu des parades à spurs
l'ex premier ministre est alors invité à
joindre le conseil d'administration et
accepte de paris à new york de monaco
aux bermudes
brian mulroney assiste aux réunions du
ca les administrateurs sont rémunérés au
moins cent mille dollars par année
said rodez est incorporé aux bermudes
un paradis fiscal où le taux
d'imposition est de 0% en 2005 la
présence aux bermudes de ces drôles
deans est minimale deux employées pour
gérer une fortune de plus d'un milliard
de dollars
[Musique]
en réponse à nos questions prend une
bonne journée confirme que c'est hydro
holding ne paient pas d'impôts aux
bermudes mais dit que la société payer
des impôts dans les pays où elle faisait
d'affaires cette société fait elle
vraiment de l'évitement fiscal dans mon
esprit c'est une pratique très anti
sociale nous avons montré des documents
confidentiels de la fuite au professeur
de comptabilité prime c'est qu'un ancien
premier ministre est liée à ce type de
société il aurait d'abord dû évaluer à
quel point les activités de cette
société sont transparentes
or c'est presque une opération de style
militaire ici les étapes que vous devez
prendre pour donner l'apparence et je
souligne le mois par an ce que les
structures financières sont légitimes
pendant ce temps l'enquète du sirius
ford en fait ce britannique bat son
plein au sujet des allégations de
corruption liés aux contrats al yamamah
en 2006 les autorités britanniques
découvrent que british aerospace avait
transféré des centaines de millions de
livres sterling par des sociétés aux
îles vierges britanniques
selon le guardian une partie des fonds
auraient transité par des comptes en
suisse lié à wafiq sailly
puis tout a basculé pour l'équipe d'
enquête ils sont allés en suisse pour
enquêter sur ses comptes dès qu'ils ont
demandé l'accès le ciel leur est tombé
sur la tête
ouafik l'a dit à bandar bandar a pris au
vol vers londres pour rencontrer le
premier ministre britannique tony blair
et a déclaré que cela devait cesser s'il
enquête se poursuit les saoudiens laisse
entendre que leur pays cessera toute
collaboration avec le royaume uni en
matière de lutte anti terrorisme trois
jours plus tard tony blair demande au
procureur général de mettre fin à
l'enquêté serious fraud office
je crois que c'est un moment
incroyablement sombre pour la justice et
la démocratie britannique
mais cela montre aussi le pouvoir de
l'arabie saoudite en grande bretagne
cela montre l'influencé extraordinaire
de gens comme moi fixé aux pipots la
coiffe excès et pendant toutes ces
années
brian mulroney a continué siéger au
conseil d'administration de cidre
holding jusqu'en 2012 il me semble très
improbable que bright n'oublie ni n'ai
pas été au courant de ces allégations
tout à fait sensationnel qui étaient
publiés tous les jours dans le cas d'une
et qui été reprise dans les médias
internationaux
cela
en
brahim journée à décliner nos demandes
d'entrevue
mais en réponse à nos questions son
avocat dit monsieur mulroney connaît ou
a fixé id depuis plus de vingt ans il
est un homme remarquable
un investisseur qui a connu beaucoup de
succès et un grand philanthrope il est
aussi un bon ami écrit-il
après la pause les paradise peppers
révèle un autre détail étonnant
ouafik sayid s'identifient comme citoyen
canadien
pourquoi voudrait-il le passeport
et comment en aurait-il obtenu
voix fixe ayed est associé à l'une des
transactions militaires les plus
corrompus de l'histoire britannique
dans cette deuxième partie d' enquête
nous tenterons de comprendre comment ce
milliardaire a obtenu un passeport
canadien
lorsque web fixe et 2 reçoit son
doctorat honorifique à l'université
saint francis xavier en 2015 on
mentionne au passage un lien étonnant
avec le canada qui ne semble pas avoir
été divulguées publiquement auparavant
en épluchant les données départ des
spurs nous trouvons bel et bien la
confirmation la photocopie d'un
passeport canadien
pour le journaliste denquête dvd qui
croyait tout connaître du milliardaire
la surprise est totale
c'est très difficile de comprendre
pourquoi il ne vit pas au canada il a
une adresse fiscale à monaco mais il n'y
habite pas il vit en grande-bretagne
il a une maison dans la campagne
britannique et un appartement à londres
c'est une découverte qui me stupéfient
ce temps et chose mais pourquoi les
riches étrangers désire-t-il obtenir la
citoyenneté canadienne en raison des
avantages qu'un passeport canadien
procure selon l'avocat richard kurland
pour un milliardaire au moyen orient
c'est le meilleur passeport possible
parce qu'on peut voyager librement
partout au monde sans visa presque et on
paie pas d'impôt au canada ont poussé la
citoyenneté mais on paie pas d'impôts
pense que n'est pas physiquement présent
au canada le canada offrait jusqu'à
récemment une porte d'entrée spéciale
pour les étrangers bien nantis comme
rafik saïd le programme d'immigrants
investisseurs
en échange d'investissements créateurs
d'emplois au canada
ces immigrants obtenait le statut de
résident permanent ou à fixer dit avoir
eu recours à ce programme en
investissant dans la société jordan
petrolium une société pétrolière et
gazière albertaine mais avant d'obtenir
la citoyenneté
les investisseurs devaient vivre au
canada pendant trois ans dans un
document provenant des paris nice people
ou à fixer id fait référence à un
passeport émis à paris en 1996
le passeport émis à à paris oui
intéressant pourquoi si c'était un
renouvellement oui ce ce procès me
d'habitude les personnes qui résident au
canada qui devient citoyenneté du canada
au canada vont recevoir leur premier
passeport dans les 48 heures une semaine
au canada
pas à paris ouafik sud at il vraiment
habité au canada pendant trois ans au
registre des entreprises du québec le
nom de wafiq saïd a paraît il est le
seul actionnaire et administrateur d'une
société à numéro fondée en 1988 elle est
située au 1010 rue sherbrooke ouest à
montréal bur ou 400 le destin chevroux
ajuster la pendant un période 10 ans
mais au 23e étage au quatrième c'était
le cabinet de mes collègues était
avocate en matière d'immigration et elle
avait eu à comme clientèle du monde / tu
qui venait du moyen-orient dans les
rapports annuels de la société ou à
fixer déclara bits et non pas monaco ou
à londres mais bien à montréal aux 55 90
rue les gares et dans le quartier côte
des neiges
son nom apparaît même dans un vieux
bottin téléphonique à partir de ce matin
nous avons trouvé une locataire qui
vivait dans le même immeuble à l'époque
et les routes ni s'ils étaient plus les
gens sensibles j'en fais mes étudiants
ni logement ni à ottawa
moi je démarrais en eau au troisième le
milliardaire ou à fixer lui affirme dans
le rapport annuel de sa société à voir
occuper l'appartement numéro 1 un
demi-sous-sol chose non c'est ce
monsieur là non
non plus c'est pas dans l'appartement
ainsi son égard y faire c'est rassembler
pas assez à l'intérieur de votre
appartement non quoi les probabilités
que la milliardaire habite un
appartement ici devrait vous au mal
moins qu il gagne le 6 49 secondes
j'ai eu plusieurs milliardaires comme
client depuis 89
j'ai jamais vu un milliardaire qui avait
l'intention de s'installer dans un des
fils de m
dans le troisième et dernier rapport
annuel déposé par wafiq saïd les
activités de sa société canadienne sont
décrites comme étant indéterminée et
imprécises activités indéterminée et
imprécises et si je travaillais à titre
d'avocat pour le département si toi des
migrations à l'époque je soulève le
drapeau rouge parce que c'est impossible
d'obtenir la citoyenneté du canada
avec cette offre est uniquement ses
preuves
alors comment at il pu obtenir la
citoyenneté canadienne
avec un tel dossier le gouvernement a le
pouvoir d'accorder la citoyenneté dans
des cas exceptionnels
si c'est dans l'intérêt national ou bien
on dans la citoyenneté de faire son
public comme on l'a fait avec le dalaï
lama ou bien savard fait cottagers à la
personne va déposer la demande de
citoyenneté
ça va être sont la preuve requis un peu
maïs comme dossier i
l'administration va identifier le
dossier abaca numéro va prendre le
dossier il traité à part en secret en
réponse à nos questions
hu a fixé dit avoir vécu au canada
pendant trois ans et dit avoir utilisé
fréquemment le petit appartement de la
rue légaré
préférez plutôt vivre à l'hôtel lors de
ses séjours avec sa famille au canada
doit fixer d'affirmer avoir obtenu la
citoyenneté canadienne en suivant la loi
à la lettre
pourtant tout au long de cette période
des journaux et des documents officiels
rapportent que wafiq saïd diriger son
empire depuis londres pour l'avocat
which crawling bien des questions
demeurent sans réponse
le canada peut suspendre le passeport on
fait dans d'autres dossiers
on peut réexaminer la façon par laquelle
cette personne a obtenu la citoyenneté
du canada qui a été responsable qui a
pris la décision mais pour protéger le
nom du canada
il faut vraiment poser des questions
contrôleur ce dossier
dans quelles circonstances wafiq saïd
ibrahim rooney se sont ils rencontrés ou
afic sayedi l'avoir connue en 2002 par
l'entremise de l'homme d'affaires
québécois paul desmarais
l'ancien premier ministre se retrouve
une nouvelle fois sur la sellette pour
ses liens avec des intermédiaires
controversé après sa carrière politique
mulroney avait vu sa réputation entachée
pour avoir accepté 225 mille dollars en
argent comptant du marchand d'armes
allemand karlheinz schreiber octobre
un peu plus d'un an après coiffic saïd
est obtenu son doctorat honorifique
brahim launay est de retour à
l'université saint francis xavier
l'ancien premier ministre vient
d'annoncer la création d'un nouvel
institut de gestion à son nom un projet
qui l'aidera à redorer son blason mais
des documents obtenus grâce à la loi
d'accès à l'information nous apprennent
que wafiq saïd l'ami controversé de
brian mulroney s'est engagé à y
contribuer 4 millions de dollars c'est
brian mulroney lui même qui a négocié
l'entente signée en mars 2015 avec wafiq
saïd quelques semaines avant que
celui-ci n'obtienne son doctorat
honorifique de l'université
ces documents suggèrent qu'il ya une
sorte de transactions ce n'est plus en
doctorat honorifique
si c'est fait de cette manière là parce
qu'un doctorat honorifique c'est quelque
chose qui ne se vend pas point selon
ceux qui ont enquêté sur wafiq said
le milliardaire a voulu redorer son
image et du même coup redorer celle de
son ami brian mulroney
[Musique]
brian mulroney a mon avis tu auras joué
un rôle essentiel pour que wafiq saïd
reçoivent un doctorat honorifique de son
alma mater il participe sciemment au
processus de réhabilitation de celui qui
a facilité la transaction d'équipement
militaire la plus corrompu de l'histoire
est riche d'un disque
[Musique]